all right Travis hey Travis uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally I'm from Leesburg Virginia
about 30 miles west of DC
and tell me about your family you had
Mom and Dad yeah a pretty normal
childhood um nothing to like traumatic
um but they got divorced when they were
four uh my dad yeah
so my mom raised my brother and I
brother's like about two years older
than me
and my dad was in Virginia Beach while
we were in Northern Virginia so um it
was only like about a four hour drive so
we kept uh in touch with us and visit us
and especially when it came to like
football games you know he was uh he
played college ball coached you know me
and my brother growing up that's what we
trained for and that's what our dad was
all about so you know that was that was
basically our our life uh from you know
a younger kid to college basically you
know we both played college football my
brother played Virginia Tech
um like all region running back in high
school you know
um got a full ride to VMI Virginia
yeah so I went from that to a whole
another
level you know at first it was just
alcohol and and uh you know that just
kind of got me started you know feeling
good took away all the anxiety fears
that had you know and so that led to not
caring about uh trying other drugs
basically you know marijuana was a I
probably smoked that every day for
I don't know how long and then came
cocaine and uh that took it to another
level at that point I was already I was
actually playing football at VMI
um so you know cocaine led to crack and
crack took me down a really dark Road
really bad and really fast
um
you know I I just lost uh all ambition
um
you know I got kicked out of school lost
my scholarship
um things just things uh I took uh some
highly uh risky dramatic like uh like uh
missions to get high like desperate
you know um
after the porn gig didn't work out
uh that took me to uh
Robin
[Music]
drug dealers in Baltimore City the
ghetto so I don't know if you've ever
been to Bob I was one of the roughest
scariest places I've been there yeah so
I was like in my mid-20s you know I was
still you know I just gotten out I think
doing some time I don't know if it was
prison or jail just jail I think that
point I was you know pretty pretty like
healthy
guy on the beach in Laguna Beach asked
me uh
one day if I wanted to do some porn or
no he said do I want a model for board
shorts
and I was just like sure sure you know
whatever whatever I didn't care you know
I went to Laguna Beach where his house
was got there and it was a whole
different you know
he's basically like do you want to make
more money I do porn I'm like hell yeah
I'll be a porn star you know what I mean
like let's do it they gave me the
application is that the crack talking
huh is that the crack talking yeah that
was the crack I mean I wouldn't have
done that you know is there a big
difference between cocaine and crack big
difference in terms of your decision
making and oh yeah crackers are like a
much like intense much more intense drug
I mean uh the high and the lows way
intense especially the low I don't want
to I don't want to stay down or be down
at all you know
so um anyways the whole thing with porn
was you know uh
was not to bust too early you gotta be
like yeah I mean I didn't want to be
that guy you know and I wasn't doing I
was I was actually I was actually in
Cali at the time from from the East
Coast trying to get clean I came out to
get clean
so
um
I told myself I'm just gonna do a little
bit of heroin for the for that so I can
make money I'm not gonna like keep doing
it or not whatever you know
so
that needless to say didn't work out I
mean I I the producer was asking me like
what's wrong with you you can't you know
do I need to get better females better
looking females like what's going on
with you because I couldn't I couldn't
um
I couldn't ejaculate you know I couldn't
bust
and he was he couldn't believe it you
know because these girls are like ah you
know I was like and I finally like after
like the second time I mean the first
time you had to take Pina Colada mix and
go you know behind me and and squirt it
like I was you know exactly so he uh
he he said basically I I ended up uh
sitting him down and telling him look
man I got I got a problem
um you know uh it's not it's not too
it's not too bad right now I'm just
hooked on some pills
um you know trust me it'll be different
next time but that next time wasn't
different it was the same thing so he
told me to go get clean I never got
clean never went back
so
um that was that was like probably the
the beginning of like the The Desperate
Measures that I took to get the drug but
prior to that on the East Coast
um
you know I did some things that like I
told you in Baltimore
that were uh
probably would have got me killed
everybody got me killed easily you know
they're talking um
you know going down in the inner city
inner city looking
looking just like a pretty much a
college student a healthy college
student you know just like uh normal and
trying to get dope and then they keep
getting turned away and turned away
because they think I'm a cop
you know
I got I got super frustrated you know
found myself
a gun found myself a fake badge and I
went down there and as soon as the the
middleman would come to the car I tell
them what I wanted
and as soon as you got back you know I'd
be like Baltimore please get on the
ground right now get on the ground you
know
and just just real intense you know real
quick real loud just you know get them
all frazzled and immediately they go to
the ground immediately go down and I
grab I grabbed the dope and I get in the
car in the driveway
any money too and the money and whatever
they had on them and they got to the
point where uh this this was like
becoming like I was doing this uh you
know frequently let's say like
three or four times a week for like a
month straight in the same neighborhood
yeah we're we're but the neighborhood
that like was like close to home that I
would not do that in you know don't [ __ ]
in your backyard type [ __ ] guy came up
to me real nice guy uh and he said look
Travis you need to stop dude they know
what you're doing look at your car dude
you gotta you gotta you got like red
stripes going down the this camera is
all beat up from just he's like dude
they know they know what you're doing
right they don't want you man you got to
stop now you're gonna they're gonna kill
you as soon as you get into the projects
and I was just like that's that's when I
just backed off man I knew I needed help
so that's when I decided to come out to
Cali I got an older brother out here and
get clean and then I I ended up not
getting clean
um end up getting like two two prison
terms out here distribution of uh heroin
uh just a maniac still
um I was going down and and Robin Robin
uh some of these dealers just straight
up just taken out of their hand I was
getting foot chased I was you know
tackled getting fights like just a
maniac man I was just a maniac like I
didn't care you know just didn't care
care now I say I calmed down a lot
though I've calmed down I got I had like
uh about a year clean I had a nice
girlfriend I loved her to death like um
I had a good job bought my first car I
had a little BMW I was doing loans up in
this in Santa Ana and Orange County
um but I saw that the relationship was
going way downhill and I don't you know
live it was because I was hiding my
addiction and lying almost killed this I
bought a Pomeranian puppy and um
you know uh for Christmas
um
and she fell in love with the puppy you
know it like it was great everything was
cool you know the puppy's growing up a
little bit and then about the puppies
like five months old I think it was
I had lost a sack of Fentanyl
right I didn't know where it went she
comes in a room with the puppies like
Travis what's going what's wrong with my
dog
and I look at the dog he's like
slobbering and his eyes closed I was
like get in the [ __ ] car right now
let's go
let's go let's go let's go I had to tell
her everything on the way to the to the
uh the emergency vet you know she's
crying dog's like dying and I'm telling
her like that I'm sorry I'm like crying
too like I got I can't like I love this
I can't believe I did this like the dog
died from fentanyl huh the dog died from
no they ended up giving the dog a little
bit of like uh Narcan
and saving a dog oh they did yeah they
say the dog but the red relationship
didn't get saved there's no Narcan for
the relationship right but one thing you
know like
I guess like there was like a
you know
she she loved the fact that like at
least in those those situations
I'm still gonna like try to save the dog
I'm still gonna be honest I'm not gonna
just I don't know yeah I mean and let
the dog die that's not me
and I deep down inside like I know that
like um I have really good intentions
you still still have some ethics right I
still have that yeah and what is your
drug now fentanyl fentanyl so you switch
from crack to fentanyl at some point
yeah well heroin heroin I didn't think
I'd ever leave heroin man I was like as
soon as that drunk in my body man it was
like this is it man how do you compare
crack to heroin crack sucks crack is
like the devil man I see these guys out
here on it man it's so it's all I think
it's coming back now like really a lot
of these youngsters are doing it man and
like they're just stealing from their
friends man I got this twice now my
car's sitting over here on Maple and
seventh man and then I know like yeah
huh you're sleeping in your car now I'm
seeing my car but someone stole my key
and uh and you know I'm not hanging out
with the you know the best group I love
I love these guys they have good good
good people but the crack is really like
the ones the ones that are doing crack
are the ones that are really like you
know I could see like going downhill
and you know unfortunately you know I'm
hanging out with them
you know I'm I left when my girlfriend I
broke up I was heartbroken I was just I
wanted to go somewhere where I could be
left alone and do my thing and Skid Row
was it man you know
you can do whatever you want down here
yeah honestly I think everybody should
at least
come see visit Skid Row from the outside
no matter what dude I think it's like
it's got It's like for as far as bad as
it is it's almost like uh it's almost
like something you have to see you know
what I mean yeah you have to see it like
it doesn't get much crazier than it's
good about it's hard to imagine
I mean some of the roads like they're
not even like
almost like they're not even working
anymore because there's so many
crazies walking through it like you know
what I mean you don't even like it's
just it's like it looks almost deserted
everyone says that you know I've been to
Kensington and done this and I've done
it in skid row for years
comparing Kensington and uh Skid Row
I I think Skid Row is a million times
worse because in on Skid Row everyone's
hiding in a tent if you knew what was
going on in the tents
you'd understand how how out of control
Skid Row is in in Kensington
there's there's very few tents and
everyone's out in the sidewalk and you
can see it all so it looks worse
but in reality Skid Row is much worse
yeah mental illness here is so out of
control it is it is
it's just insane
so what do you what do you do now how
old are you I'm 43.
43. is there a diction in your family
uh so my older brother will tell you
with him he um he was a
he was
addicted the same as me but different
drugs I don't want to really want to put
his business out there but his his was a
little bit different than mine um but uh
you know and that is
you know it's all it's all super tough
man and it's hard to it's hard to get
clean I mean but he did he got I'm so
proud of him now he's got that's that's
gonna be my driving force like I look
forward to
um to getting clean
uh he went through a program he did like
a little rehab and like he dedicated
himself for a year
oh yeah he said I'm gonna do this for a
year if I don't like it I can always go
back and refund my misery they say you
know so he uh I'm so I'm really proud of
him man he's him and I are super close I
mean he's two years older we
you know what advice does he give you
he's just waiting my family's waiting
you know they're good people man they're
not gonna be ready until you're ready
yeah they're not they're not they're not
trying to like you know they know that
like they can't there's not much they
they can do they just they're just
waiting for me to get sober but my
brothers my brother's the guy that you
know is going to be like my uh my my my
support you know right from he said I'll
come down there right I'll fly out there
right now dude I'll get you to rehab
let's do this let's let's do this man
this is fourth quarter dude
what's your biggest fear now
because fentanyl is a tough drug my
biggest fear is like tough drug to put
down yeah it's not getting clean and you
know seeing
just seeing my family pass away
you had your life to live all over again
what would you have done differently
I'll call or anything you know because
that's pretty much what led me down down
the whole the path you feel like alcohol
is the first gateway yeah the depart
which led to crote
Coke and then the crack and then heroin
yeah that was it you missed Matt
no like I've actually missed heroin a
lot like you skipped crystal meth yeah
that wasn't a big part of my my story
it's uh it's it's in and out like I do
it frequently not as much but um
you know it's it's there you know it's
but I I don't ever do meth unless I've
got plenty of uh opiates you know I mean
what do you think most people don't
understand about drug addiction
the level the level of
the I guess the level of pain and
suffering that that the drug addict goes
through whether they're
you know high or coming off it or
whatever you just have that uh that that
that feeling of like uh hopelessness you
know is also the shame and guilt the
shame and the guilt like it's so intense
you know it's like I don't think you
know you can people think you guys are
walking around having a great time yeah
proud of yourselves no you're just kind
of you're so much shame that you can't
even contact your family yeah you're
covering up covering up the pain you
know what I mean yeah that's why I don't
even care about having I haven't had a
phone since I got down here
yeah I've talked to my mom maybe once
and uh you know
my brother said my dad's like you can't
even hardly talk to him right now about
it
what kind of emotions you go through
down here down here yeah um yeah here
like especially being on skid row man
it's just he's like uh
because you get you get you get your uh
the people that you think are your
friends you know you get things that
stolen and things that you feel betrayed
so like
sometimes you're just stuck with like
that like super loneliness you know just
real lonely
you know like you know you shouldn't
like you shouldn't be down here you know
and that you should be I should be
calling and getting in I should be
taking steps to to go get clean
not like steps to go get more you know
what I mean
and uh I know I'm close I know I'm close
to that point I just um I keep
stretching it out one more day one more
day
so uh I don't know maybe this interview
like will help too because you know when
you sit down and talk about it you
realize how much pain there is you know
what's your favorite memory in your life
my favorite man would have to be
probably um
probably signing my letter of intent to
go to go play division one football
that's great
is that probably your biggest regret too
is that didn't work out yeah I love
biggest regret was just you know I I
wanted to to play ball at that time and
at the same time I wanted to still party
and it didn't mix and then my
the time I like
my ambitions just got lower and then uh
then I started you know then I got
locked up and then I lost the
scholarship everything just kind of like
I didn't care anymore you know
that's the biggest thing is it takes
away your passion you know it takes away
your past seems to take away your
ability to just make anything work out
in your life too oh yeah you don't get
you know you're not gonna keep a job
you're not going to get a job you're not
gonna
keep your housing you're not gonna keep
your kids you're just going to get that
drug not finishing school was another
big one you know
not finished in college I'm probably the
only one in my family that didn't finish
that didn't finish college you're the
only one yeah
you come from a solid family real solid
yeah thank you both your parents had
jobs oh yeah my mom was a teacher for
like 40 years she just retired
um
she was in the the uh up there in
Northern Virginia Loudoun County
District what'd your dad do my dad he
was a um he worked for a book publishing
company a big one sold textbooks to uh
colleges throughout the United States
make good money yeah real successful so
you're the black sheep
yeah my brother wasn't was right there
behind me and so but he's redeemed
himself he has you know I mean my
brother's one of those guys that you
know no one probably would have thought
he's older he's yeah he's older just as
crazy I mean
it's nice you have that
role model for oh yeah he turned he
turned like
to get into using of drugs you know
which is like an all-day thing you know
into like everything everything he does
now is all about
um he's working on himself how can he
get better is he has he kind of
transferred his
vibration his addiction into oh yeah
well I mean in a good way though like
yeah he doesn't yeah he does like gym
meditation that's what I'm saying yeah I
guess my point is you can't just stop
using the drug you have to start running
marathons or start going to the gym or
start working on some project or just
doing something to replace that yeah
that's what I'm saying I'm glad I have
him like to uh because when I get sober
I can just I just picture us like you
know throwing the ball getting on the
beach and going to the gym together and
doing things that we enjoy doing as as
kids you know growing up
yeah
Travis what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
um
my lesson is like
no matter how bad it is or how bad it
gets or
there's always there's always
a way to overcome it there's always
there's always a way out but no one's
going to do it for you you know I mean
I know that like even though I did a lot
of time you know for various things
and I know that that little bit of
sobriety time I had in prison and I was
able to laugh and cry and feel some
things
um
uh gave me gave me like uh probably
saved my life in a way that I had those
breaks and also and also feeling that
how good it felt to be sober I mean I
it's still it's still not too far
behind me I could still you know I mean
where I wanna I wanna get I want to get
back to feeling like that again you know
yeah wish you all the luck in the world
man thank you I hope you're following
your
brother's footsteps thank you thank you
big fan of yours bye-bye thank you
Travis thank you man thanks